[Música]
bienvenidos a esta nueva emisión de los
observadores de france 24 100% en
imágenes de aficionados esta semana
iremos a india donde circulan cada vez
más informaciones falsas sobre unas
manifestaciones de agricultores pero
primero vamos a esta ciudad donde
nuestro equipo obtuvo el testimonio
miembro de la etnia más al sobreviviente
del ataque a un campamento en darfur
[Aplausos]
es la segunda vez desde 2020 que este
campamento de desplazados en darfur el
saqueado y quemado los responsables
miembros de una tribu árabe respaldados
por mercenarios conocidos bajo el nombre
de jean ya hui actualmente más de 100
mil desplazados de la etnia masalit ya
están repartidos por el geneina la
capital de darfur occidental desde
principios de febrero la ciudad ya no
está ocupada pero las detenciones se
mantienen en la región nuestro
observador sobrevivió a la masacre teme
una nueva ola mortal contra su etnia
ustedes no podrán ver su rostro pero
acepto dar su testimonio por teléfono
y ya el sábado 16 de enero nos
sorprendieron entre las 8 y 30 y las 9
de la mañana con un ataque en el ala
este del campamento con disparos y luego
empezó otro asalto en el ala sur y luego
un tercer ataque en el ala norte era un
ataque sobre todos los frentes de
nuestro campamento y aquí había armas de
todo tipo pesadas medianas un incendio
se apoderaba del campamento el cielo
estaba negro por el humo muchas personas
murieron dentro del campamento las balas
derribaban a los que trataron de
escaparse y nadie intervino también hubo
muchos disparos y hubo varias
violaciones
ahora el campamento de crimen está
totalmente bajo el control de las
milicias janjaweed y agreden a dos que
regresan al lugar para recuperar lo que
queda de sus pertenencias actualmente
estamos en centros de acogida temporales
en la capital donde hay más de 75
centros similares la situación
humanitaria es muy dura y los
desplazados necesitan alimentos
alojamiento nadie en este momento hace
frío y entre ellos hay recién nacidos
niños y adultos mayores
sin agua tampoco hay ninguna medida para
luchar contra la pandemia de kobe 19
ouija el mini mini norad corona ya según
un informe de la oficina para la
coordinación de asuntos humanitarios de
la onu las violencias intercomunitarias
en darfur aumentaron un 87 por ciento
durante la segunda mitad del año 2020 en
comparación con el año 2019
desde hace meses indian enfrente a unos
disturbios de sus agricultores que
protestan contra un proyecto de
privatización del sector agrícola según
ellos esta privatización beneficiaría
principalmente a los grandes grupos y en
particular amenazaría el precio mínimo
de compra de productos como el arroz o
el trigo estos agricultores crearon
entonces barreras en varios estados de
india y bloquean desde hace varias
semanas los alrededores de nueva de su
menú ya es periodista del medio de
verificación indio good life está
cubriendo esta manifestación y si se dio
cuenta que cada vez hay más
desinformación sobre este movimiento el
principal argumento detrás de estas
informaciones falsas es que se trata de
una movilización contra el orden
establecido según el gobierno cuando el
tema se convirtió en una noticia también
empezaron las noticias falsas
haciendo un estimado puedo decir que
cerca del 60 por ciento de las noticias
falsas tratan de desacreditar el
movimiento pero 40 por ciento tratan por
el contrario de glorificarlo
por ejemplo salió esta portada de
national geographic donde se ve a un
agricultor con un turbante se compartió
para animar las manifestaciones como
para decir hasta national geographic que
está cubriendo este tema pero en
realidad se trata de una noticia falsa
sobre las protestas de los agricultores
la página india ponga ha hecho público
85 artículos de verificación
relacionados con las manifestaciones de
los agricultores y surgió una temática
en particular la de las noticias falsas
en torno a la comunidad si inicialmente
hubo noticias falsas sobre los ciclos
fueron porque los manifestantes
empezaron principalmente en los pueblos
dependía y haryana vendían y haryana son
estados muy agrícolas
[Música]
entonces al principio las informaciones
falsas eran sobre los agricultores los
internautas afirmaban que no eran
agricultores sino empresarios con dinero
había muchas fotos de carros y de
tractores personalizados circulando por
internet que decían como estos hombres
pueden ser agricultores pobres si tienen
estos vehículos
por ejemplo este vídeo que fue
presentado con unos tractores de
cultores de ninja en realidad fue
grabado en alemania durante las fiestas
de navidad el año sus 20
aunque circulan muchas noticias falsas
sobre la comunidad si el principal
objetivo siguen siendo los musulmanes de
la india la reacción de bombay redactó
al menos 18 artículos sobre este tema
hemos visto varios vídeos donde se ve a
un policía jalando a un hombre psiquis
del pelo el policía le quita su turbante
y las personas dicen miren es un
musulmán disfrazado decir que está
participando en las manifestaciones
pero en realidad el vídeo fue grabado en
2011 y se trataba de una manifestación
en pendjab que fue sacada de contexto
las personas que publican estas
informaciones falsas tienen una obsesión
y es que las manifestaciones están
infiltradas por musulmanes
para ello no se trata de una
manifestación de agricultores son
musulmanes disfrazados de agricultores o
musulmanes disfrazados de manifestantes
que quieren llamar la atención sobre
otros temas como una especie de
intención oculta resaltada por los
musulmanes
quiere describirla a nuestro equipo
whatsapp twitter correo electrónico y
todos los contactos aparecen en pantalla
envíenos sus fotos y videos que puede
ser el próximo observador de france 24
hasta pronto
[Música]